des cris et des invectives au milieu des
passants de la consommation et du trafic
de drogue une cohabitation plus
fréquente avec des personnes vulnérables
la STM veut remettre de l'ordre dans son
réseau et améliorer le sentiment de
sécurité les fins de sécurité c'est un
sentiment c'est relatif à chaque
personne mais on est conscient que
présentement il y a plus de situations
imprévisible puis on veut améliorer la
situation prendre le métro le soir
probablement que je serai un peu plus
prudent
métro parisiens donc ici je me sens
vraiment en sécurité une augmentation
effectivement des incivilités en fait
entre 2020 année de pandémie et 2022
quand l'achat landage a commencé à
reprendre le nombre de signalements a
augmenté de 33%
la STM va engager 20 constatables
spéciaux supplémentaires 20 agents de
propreté et c'est une nouveauté 20
ambassadeurs de sûreté qui n'auront pas
le pouvoir d'intervenir mais le devoir
de rassurer je pense que c'est une bonne
initiative qui a plus de gens qui soient
visibles on voit très peu d'employés les
agents les constats spéciaux de la STM
il y en a pas tant que ça mais viser les
personnes vulnérables avec davantage de
répression n'est pas la solution selon
les organismes communautaires
la personne qui passe dans le métro pour
aller travailler ou la personne qui est
obligée d'être couchée par terre parce
qu'elle a pas de place survivre le plan
de la STM doit aussi assurer une
meilleure sécurité au personnel le
principal syndicat a déjà constaté une
hausse de 25% des agressions cette année
par rapport à 2022 et il pointe aussi
les baisses de fréquence des bus et
métro quinc en couple le service mais
cela
un impact direct parce que les clients
sont moins sont moins patients on a
beaucoup aussi de la clientèle entre eux
qui sont agressifs et ça crée des
arguments ça crée des frustrations le
sentiment de frustration un autre
chantier pour la STM ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal